No one dishes it out like family.
Get ready to be old-schooled.
Nothing like family
to keep you woke.
And telling it like it is.
Ready.
-Call 'em out.
-Let me hear it, let me hear it.
Rapid fire.
I remember being punished.
We knew we had it coming,
and it was coming hard.
I love being punished.
I just get to go on Snapchat.
Oh, you going to learn today.
Mm-hmm.
Being a mom means enforcing
the rules with a firm "no."
Rules?
I think you mean "suggestions."
-No.
-What happens if mom says no?
Ask dad.
We love having our family
living with us
so we can help raise the kids.
It's like I always said,
it takes a village.
It takes way too long to get
any hot water in this house.
Oh, I don't even want to know.
I'm proud of how
we raise our kids in Seattle.
They're mature,
well-behaved children of God.
-Get me a root beer.
-What's the magic word?
Now.
Oh...
Yes, 9-1-1, we got a homicide.
Family always keeps it real.
Nobody brings you down like
the people who brought you up.
What happened to
"Mi casa es su casa"?
Mi casa, my casa.
If you don't like that, pay renta.
Just because you're related
doesn't mean you relate.
-Let me try.
-Oh!
-Oh...
-Oops.
We're one big happy family
under one happy roof.
Oh!